so you always get an x-intercept and
y-intercept for a cubic and that's why
now we're gonna fix it on what happens
when you've not got not just one but you
can actually get a whole bunch okay so
here's the graph we're going to now look
at this is number three okay now I'm
giving this graph to you or rather I'm
giving this equation to you in a nicely
factorized form later on you will get
you know messy ones that are not
factorized and part of your work will be
to factorize them right but at the
moment we're really only familiar with
factorizing quadratics like this we know
the rules of this if I gave you a cubic
that was in this expanded form you'd be
like where do I begin
right desmos help me please right so at
the moment at the moment I'm gonna give
you sort of the ready-made version where
everything is already factorized and
nice and neat for you okay so just like
before I'm going to start with this most
basic piece of information I'm going to
start looking for intercepts because
once I've got those I'm like oh these
like anchor points I know I go through
them and then I can try to fit
everything together okay so which
intercepts would you like to view with X
or Y you want to begin with the y
intercept okay that's enough
y intercepts are generally easy to find
because this is all you have to do I
just go X equal 0 BAM you get a number
out okay so sorry before I take your
question I'm gonna take this suggestion
festival run with it okay so when x
equals 0 what's Y gonna equal we've been
hold your force per second hard you
thought you said we got a lot of ideas
coming out here right if I was feeling
mean to you this morning I'd make you
vote but I'm not okay because I've been
modeling for you how you don't need to
guess right you don't need to guess
right we find it by doing the
substitution right now if you're if you
were good enough if you're good enough
you'll be able to do the substitution in
your head but we evidently are not so
I'm going to write the substitution y
equals 0 times 0 minus 2 times 0 plus 3
right
last I checked that was negative 2 last
I checked that was 3
but this guy here just stay zero right
so what's the whole thing equal to it's
zero thank you very much okay zero
multiplied by anything is zero okay so
what does this tell us about our graph
yeah hacen oh yeah go ahead
okay so the question was can we
factorize this object here and change it
the first thing I should say is it's
factorized right now that that's the
factorized form what you're asking is
could I expand it out and you can't
expand it out if you want the question
is is that a useful thing to do at least
at this moment but I think we've kind of
gotten to the answer that we wanted
without having to expand it okay but I
will come to expand it in a minute okay
how nice is yeah okay good we've got
coordinates out of this I've got next
and a y so this is zero zero isn't it
I'm going to put it on there okay now in
the very first graph we did this morning
we were like cool
I've got an x intercept and a
y-intercept all together right and then
like that's it I don't need to find
y-intercepts anymore but cubics and
other polynomials turn out to have sort
of more more sort of features that's why
we're focusing them on them as different
things this is the y-intercept how do I
find the x-intercept
yeah sure Bobby okay so if I let the X
is equal to zero right if I I'm gonna
I'm gonna take your idea cuz you're you
I think you know what you're trying to
say but don't have the language yet to
say it right if I let X equal zero this
is what happens yeah I get this right
but I want to do something a bit
different right I want to let y equal
zero now if I do that when y equals
you're right go ahead and write this
with me okay
this then gets to what che values
talking about here's a fire zero over
here in the left hand sign right this is
saying hey I've got three things they're
multiplied together and when you do that
you should get zero at the end right
well if you multiply three objects
together and your answer is zero
at least one of those objects had to be
zero right if you took any three bless
you nonzero object right like say two
and 15 and negative one right no matter
what those objects are if none of them
is zero you won't get zero is the answer
right one of them has to be zero so I'm
actually going to look at and this is
what shared a via talking about I'm
going to look at each one individually
right so this guy here X could be 0
right we kind of already knew that did
you notice that we already knew that
what about this if I put in x equals 2
okay now just pour some in it this is a
really important moment for you to focus
okay if I point in x equals 2 these two
objects here what would they be if X
were equal to 2 what would this be
that'll be 2 what would this be this
whole object sorry I should have said
that this whole object is 5 right 2 & 5
but I don't care what value they take on
whether they're 2 or 5 or 5 million
because this guy in the middle that will
be 0 so then the whole thing will become
0 you okay with that so x equals 2 even
though it like doesn't make these things
Y it makes this one 0 so I will get 0 on
the left hand side as well
okay are you yeah you with me okay son
that's right that's right
[Music]
okay so this step here I'm including it
for the sake of completeness it doesn't
just disappear right but then I notice
oh I've already accounted for this
earlier on okay I'm gonna give another
example a second where that doesn't
happen okay but for this case I want to
give you a nice easy one x equals 2
makes this one 0 so the whole thing will
become 0 what's the last value of x that
I could put into here negative 3 x
equals negative 3 if I put this in right
these things will not be 0 but this one
will be it'll become negative 3 plus 3
which is 0 so the whole line will become
0 times some other stuff right yeah
because that's what I that's why I
started with right where Mike was that's
how I find my exit
so what a lovely question which which
x-intercept are we going to take do you
remember when we had a look at quadratic
equations right you would launch into
the quadratic formula perhaps or you'd
factorize and then you might get two
answers out which one when you're
graphing which one do you take you kind
of need both of them because you will
you're gonna take your brother it's
gonna hit your axes twice right what
does this tell you how many times is the
cubic going to hit the axes it's gonna
hit three times here here and here okay
so I'm gonna put those three spots on to
my graph okay C is the Y equation so
access is the x-axis I'm gonna put these
guys on right that's going to look like
- I go through there and then one two
okay so you can see I've got these
crosses where I know I'm going to go
through that's zero now this is a bit
weird what's the shape that goes through
all of these yeah it's gonna have to
kind of weave up and down through this
shape okay now don't draw this okay but
I'm going to put a question to you if I
go through these three points right
there are two ways that I could go
through this two ways I could go through
like this or just as equally couldn't I
also go through those three points like
this don't they both they're both my
orange in my green both go through all
three points do you agree with that it
is something to do with the sign these
guys have been positive and negative
versions of each other my question is
how would I work out which one it is
I've got a tool of my disposal I've
already used it today what could I
possibly do yeah I could put more values
in I could substitute in a point and
then see where it ends up okay so I'm
not gonna put in x equals zero cuz I
already know where that goes I'm not
gonna put x equals two I'm not gonna put
x equals negative three I already know
what happens to all of those can someone
see us to me another point how about one
that's a
nice easy number right so if I put X
equals one into this I should write this
down when x equals 1 ok let's see what
happens I'm going to get y equals 1
times 1 minus 2 times 1 plus 3 it's just
a straight substitution I haven't done
any calculating at all literally just
put all the numbers into the right spot
right ok I know what one is that's fine
what about 1 minus 2 that's negative 1
and then on the end there I've got 1
plus 3 which is 4 so my final answer
will be negative 4 so when x equals 1
the coordinates I get out of this out 1
comma negative 4 where is that the
answer is well it's not going to be up
here it's gonna be down here isn't it
right so I could put that in somewhere
like this like so